ces professeurs de musique à la base
ensuite philosophie et j'ai été
professeur de dépister dommages et
artistique à l'université européenne du
travail à bruxelles et enseignants la
sono et j'ai eu en charge les
enseignements universitaires à la
faculté de médecine de tours et ensuite
ça s'est développé au noble lille et
puis aujourd'hui à l'étranger puisque il
dit à la corée la roumanie qui
reprennent le modèle qui est elle est en
place à tour un modèle qui ces jours-ci
célèbre ses 40 ans richard forestier a
vécu et accompagner la naissance de
l'art thérapie moderne et la création de
la fra tap m derrière cet acronyme un
peu abrupte se cache
l'association française de recherches et
applications des techniques artistiques
en pédagogie et médecine vu clairement
l'école d'art thérapie de tours qui a
posé les bases de la discipline
très schématiquement elle consiste à
utiliser le pouvoir d'entraînement de
l'art comme processeur thérapeutique
[Musique]
l'art-thérapie voulait trouver non
quasiment aujourd'hui tous les lieux de
soins même si la voie royale dans les
années 50-60 était la psychiatrie
aujourd'hui vous les avez quasiment
partout ça va de de la gériatrie et ça
va des deux du milieu carcéral se gaver
le les personnes sans domicile fixe la
neurologie
les troubles somatiques puisqu'on a
facilement tendance à orienter tous car
thérapie vers le domaine psychique et
l'art est d'abord et avant tout une
activité par le corps c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des
rééducations automatique la faculté de
médecine comme le centre hospitalier de
tours sont partenaires de l'école d'art
thérapie à l'hôpital pédiatrique
clocheville
certains enfants bénéficient d'un
programme de soins appropriés je te
donne le début je t'arrête rêve ou 10
minutes c'est parti ce sport baptiste 14
ans a d'abord rencontré une
orthophoniste du centre de référence
pour les troubles du langage et des
apprentissages
après cet examen des séances d'art
thérapie lui ont été proposés ce que
l'on cherche à faire c'est que l'enfant
retrouve le chemin de sa créativité et
ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
les ressenti les émotions les
les satisfactions qu'il va éprouver
pendant ces moments assez particulier et
bien vont l'amener à débloquer un
certain nombre de ce que j'appellerais
de d'associations irrationnelle à la
faveur des interventions de l'art
thérapeute qui lui va savoir observer
lui où elles vont savoir observer
exactement ce qui se joue ce qui se noue
on encadre une activité de créativité
artistique et on est en même temps un
thérapeute salut ça va
alors comment ça va depuis la semaine
dernière
bien bien on va se remettre le tablier
d'entrée de jeu puis après on se pose
[Musique]
savourer prend confiance en moi parce
qu'ils vont à l'école ici que j'allais
faire plein de choses des chine et tout
ça donc j'avais perdu confiance en moi
et donc quand leur su la lette
d'art-thérapie qu'on pouvait en faire ma
donc que ça va aider à apprendre un peu
plus confiance en moi et puis voilà
moi je suis là juste pour leur donner
des outils pour qu'ils se révèlent et
pour qu'ils se rendent compte de leurs
capacités et de leur tout leur potentiel
moi je lé dans mes stratégies je fais en
sorte que ce soit eux qui se rendent
compte et avec les boucles de
renforcement qu'ils puissent avoir de la
gratification se sentir capable elle et
des productions s'adapter au monde
social avoir le regard critique en fait
c'est moi je leur apporte juste des
outils ma façon de les amener peut les
aider mais c'est eux qui font en séance
la majorité du travail
sa mission oui c'est un échange et c'est
ce que j'aime aussi dans l'art thérapie
à la hâte une fois plaisir il a un petit
peu plus posé quand même avec le temps
voilà un pied grandit aussi il ya
beaucoup de choses et l'évolution de
l'enfant aussi mais c'est vrai que il ya
du mieux quand même un bon leur semble
plus même au niveau de l'école sont
aperçus de certaines choses et c'est
vrai que c'est intéressant c'est en fait
que ça continue
le pouvoir de l'art c'est que quand je
fais ça elle bouge
ces quelques notes d'accordéon c'était
en janvier 2015 au siège de l'école
d'art thérapie devant un public coréen
le savoir-faire tourangeau a conquis ces
asiatiques dont nombre de compatriotes
souffrent notamment de troubles liés aux
nouvelles technologies
le travail de l'afrata pen est à la
pointe de la recherche
j'étais un petit peu surprise d'être
contacté par un professeur à new york
qui travaille dans un grand hôpital donc
la new york et qui me disait il nous
faisons de l'art thérapie est en réalité
en voyant leurs reportages me rendais
compte c'était beaucoup plus des
ateliers d'animation artistique de
grande qualité qui est qui est
véritablement les patients ne peuvent
pas tout à fait de l'art thérapie et
c'est aussi à ce moment là je me suis
rendu compte que beaucoup de pays disait
faire de l'art thérapie en réalité ils
ne sont pas à notre stade de la
recherche ont les qualités requises pour
un art thérapeute ce sont d'abord les
compétences artistiques puisque nous
recrutons dans l'école des personnes qui
sont artistes et qui connaissent bien ce
qui se passe dans les procédés
artistiques
ensuite il doit avoir un gage de sérieux
et de rigueur qu'il doit acquérir
pendant la formation c'est à dire qu'il
doit passer deux artistes à thérapeute
et devenir donc art thérapeute et donc
il doit avoir un grand sérieux et une
adaptabilité puisque l'art thérapeute
est là pour répondre aussi donc à un
besoin de soin pour des patients et doit
savoir s'adapter à la demande tant bien
que l'institution que du patient que de
l'équipe
l'école d'art thérapie de tours est la
seule en france et même en europe à
délivrer un titre officiel reconnu par
l'état
ici les apprentis sorciers n'ont pas
voix au chapitre car l'art à des
pouvoirs qu'il faut apprendre à
maîtriser l'art est une mode a été
privilégié d'expression mais
l'expression pour l'expression peut être
pathogènes éventuellement
potentiellement très dangereuse c'est
pourquoi on a besoin d'un professionnel
pour véritablement orienté et que la
personne ne se détruisent pas même avec
l'art mais consent terre et puissent
réintégrer un protocole thérapeutique
[Musique]
s'appelle les mains et pour travailler
poignets ont pas tenu oui ses pairs
continue et c'est de faire plus grand à
saint jean de braye près d'orléans
claire poupée formé à l'école d'art
thérapie de tours travaille depuis
plusieurs mois avec le même groupe
les six pensionnaires du hameau de
julien un foyer d'accueil médicalisé de
bois ni dans le loiret sont atteints
d'autisme
une fois par semaine ils répètent avec
claire un vrai théâtre a été mise à leur
disposition par la ville
ça les a valorisé et ça ça a permis à
rien qu'au niveau de l'expression
corporelle vous savez dans nos
établissements d'un des lieux on fait ce
qu'on peut avec les moyens qu'on a
et les lieux sont souvent exigus pour le
fait de se retrouver dans un lieu pareil
avec une jauge de 70 places b se sont
verts qui sont complètement ouvert 7 j
imagine que tu vois une sorcière on peut
imaginer qu'elle est au la sorcière la
la d'accord on imagine qu'elle est là
oui tu entres et tu vois la sorcière et
tu as peur d'un moment ça qu'on
s'adresse à ce qui fonctionne bien chez
quelqu'un c'est à dire on va toucher on
va pas l'enfermer dans ce qui fonctionne
pas bien haut dans ce qui est toujours
source de problèmes on va il ya une
transformation
de la souffrance et une transcendance
aussi un pouvoir de cet ordre là que
j'ai peur pour rien bonjour j'ai peur je
sais pas koch media phone fait jusqu où
ça fait le fournisseur c'est fini mais
on commence déjà à danser là d'accord tu
fais tes trois comptes commencent à
danser et après tu rentres si tu veux
allez allez lieu mercredi avec pour
visée est clair il a fait 2
je fais de la danse ballet et là c'est
la table et les verts mais tu lui mets
même si comme comme s'il était là ça
permet d'entrer en relation avec les
autres autrement et ça donne accès à un
type de relation qui n'est pas
l'explication qui n'est pas le verbal
qui n'est pas la preuve que je suis plus
fort que je suis plus beau que mais qui
est d'un autre ordre kid inquiets qui ne
nous permet d'être ensemble en fait de
nous rapprocher
je pense que ça c'est un effet
extrêmement thérapeutique
[Musique]
ce travail là n'est pas une fin en soi
mais il restaure la confiance donne
envie d'avancer et de réaliser des
projets comme pour yannick qui rêve
d'entrer dans un établissement et
service d'aidé par le travail espère
jamais dit qu'ils me paient depuis
puisque du tout gamin hélas ce que tu
fais ici sa faute et ça m'aide beaucoup
à nous même ma prononciation parce que
je pars un peu trop vite c'est même
beaucoup pop obama les choses d'avenir
questions essentielles à chacun ses
envies à chacun ses désirs qu'il soit
personnel ou qu'il concerne l'art
thérapie dans son ensemble véritablement
d'ici une vingtaine d'années ce qui
pourrait être intéressant c'est qu'il y
ait un véritable statut d'art thérapeute
et qu'ils puissent être être reconnu par
les institutions sans avoir sans être
obligé d'expliquer en détail de quoi il
s'agit à mon sens deux directions
important c'est la reconnaissance du
statut d'art thérapeute et l'intégration
de l'art thérapeute dans les équipes de
soin et deuxièmement la recherche je
pense que
à ces temps maintenant d'envisager des
protocoles de recherche qui permettent
d'évaluer de démontrer le bénéfice de
séance le bénéfice de protocole précis
pour telle ou telle indication et je
pense que l'art thérapie est arrivés à
ce degré de maturité qui devrait
l'amener à sa cellule esthétique met en
évidence la beauté
il faut savoir que la laideur fait aussi
partie n'a pas fait ce qui est important
ce n'est pas de savoir ce qu'il est beau
ou ce qui est laid mais c'est que la
personne puisse s'exprimer
ce qu'elle aime et ce qu'elle n'aime pas
et le but de l'art thérapie c'est de
mettre en évidence une modalité
particulière qui va permettre à la
personne de mettre en évidence son rôle
son style et son engagement est entendu
que leur thérapeute n'est absolument pas
détenteur du loup et heureusement
[Musique]
j'aimerais continuer dans ce projet
d'aidé d'aider les enfants avec des
troubles d'apprentissage
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire et que c'est des gens qui sont des
enfants qui sont beaucoup en difficulté
et après je vais contre j'aimerais bien
situer aussi le diplôme universitaire ce
que c'est toujours enrichissant
d'apprendre de nouvelles choses et
d'approfondir ce qu'on a appris
voilà et puis après on verra ce que la
vie m'apporte ans
ako métier je vais être paysagiste et
après peut-être le plus tard j'ai pas
travailler avec les enfants qui ont du
mal des chine mais aborde un peu près
comme moi quand perdu confiance en moi
voilà qui réussissent dans sa vie c'est
déjà pas mal j'ai trouvé un métier qui
lui plaît c'est oui puisse s'affirmer
[Musique]